welcome back everybody southwest medical
wants to remind the community how
important breast care is especially
for those at high risk take a look you
guys have a new program coming out that
is based on high risk breast care right
correct correct it's really looking and
carving out for patients and identifying
those patients who need to be followed
whether through genetic mutations
with abnormalities in previous biopsies
showing that they have an increased risk
and really trying to focus on the
community who needs to be
tested and followed more aggressively
and have a treatment plan set up
this is our next phase of our growth in
terms of growing our optimum breast care
department that's great and how do you
respond to high risk
breast cancer patients well in terms of
high risk
not just you know we kind of term once
patients go through their treatment
after their breast cancer they actually
kind of go into a survivorship program
which is a little bit different
um which in a sense you know they
survived the worst of it they need to
move forward but they still have lots of
issues that we can help them with
really with the high risk is not just
identifying those follow-ups which is a
little bit different it's identifying
the woman who hasn't had breast cancer
who has abnormalities who has family
predisposition or genetic related
mutations
and actually targeting them because
really we have
barriers to patients getting into access
in general here in vegas if not
throughout the whole country
but how best do we follow these people
and basically can we identify people
that don't even know that they're high
risk
what are those prevention options to
manage these risks for people
so the prevention options really is that
once you're identified as being high
risk based on your family history or
you've been you've actually tested for a
genetic mutation or had an abnormal
biopsy
it's most likely your primary care will
refer you in because on top of your
screening mammograms we need to develop
a plan if we need to do any other
additional studies
or at least every six months of clinical
breast examination so that's kind of how
it's identified i mean our goal here is
not to not work with our primary care
our goal here is to be an adjunct to our
primary care to help these patients
and what are some things that people can
do at home or in their own lifestyles to
to help decrease their risk
looking at watching our alcohol intake
trying to cut down and stop smoking
these are definitely added to risk
factors
trying to minimize a lot of the hormone
replacement therapy that we've been
taking the menopausal years
and really in the end it's kind of an
exercise
getting out there you know being active
you know keeping our weight down and
being active are most important things
that we can do
and seeing your doctor on a regular
basis we're starting to see more and
more
you know patients coming in and feeling
more comfortable with the screening
mammogram and i think nevada has done a
phenomenal job as compared to so many of
the other states
in terms of getting your patients
vaccinated and feeling more comfortable
please know that you do come in that
you are being screened we're all taking
the appropriate precautions
and we do see already in the country
that patients who've put off a lot of
their screening exams not just
mammograms
say colonoscopies that we're seeing in
increased cancer coming through and
really that affects
overall long-term outcomes that we
really want to tell people
certain things you can't put off and
seeing your doctor and getting your
vaccinations and getting your screening
films are probably one of them
we want to thank southwest medical for
being one of our community pride
partners we'll be right back